[Música]
o futebol
ele é casado com mulher e 35 mil que ele
será a figura jurídica
esse número é a quantidade de decisões
você olha só podia estar mais ou menos
uma vez a cada dois segundos e abençoou
24 uma lesão para que se fortaleçam a
palestra que contará você constrói com o
do homem forma de chegar a algumas das
decisões
logo na volta de tomar lições da rede
record
os assinantes da revista tinha três
moções de assinatura mostra digital os
50 melhores
uma grande revista impressa os 7200
corpo digital mais depressa talvez cf
dói
o resultado desse evento é que a grande
maioria das pessoas
escolher o ovo pochê 30 mil dólares
esses treinamentos irão representa 52
segundo grupo software duas opções uma
opção digital 50 dólares e os anglo como
processo de dólares também interessa é
que pra esse grupo de pessoas a maioria
escolheu a opção digital representa
televisão e esse é um sonho do meio de
109 e loção impressa que ninguém
escolheu porque essa opção mudou a
maioria das pessoas escolheu outro
olha essa visão que eu comecei a ensinar
sobre direitos sobre o nome que corre é
votada com relação a influenciar uma
decisão ou outra sobre isso não falei
com um total de morrer que estuda
ciência aplicada de decisões
tem até uma fórmula interessante lá mas
em 2009 e que vocês querem
escolha a opção te jogam sempre pressa
eu posso ter atuam no projeto de estudo
e uma palestra
tenho um problema na roda já é tudo isso
mas eu vou mostrar pra vocês que ela é
simplificar o acesso à área de trânsito
fundo a gente vê e elas são as duas
rodovias
a apresentação não entende faz sentido
dizer que tem volta nos influencia
envolve o chefe de tecnologia num
projecto através desse curso
[Música]
e ele chamou muita atenção no uso da
tecnologia e até o nome nessa profissão
chama irs e 130 estou diferente do
usuário
jd pessoas que são rápidas das decisões
trabalha na arquitetura decisão
desenhando todo formado e os ambientes a
gente tomar decisões
parece um amigo meu
a loja encontra um dia conhece sara e
até r l ele é a pessoa que é legal e
dessa forma lógica da fé e eu falei pra
ele essas duas teorias que você tem de
trazer a weta digital passado
agora estou com dois eu comecei a me
perguntar sobre isso aqui bolo do forno
google tv
veja aqui como aí começou o trabalho na
seleção como no show eu saí quando a
gente faz um lugar ea gente coloca o r
o é isso aí o caminho para a gente vai
combater a crise com essa sombra
proveito de uma largada ruim quanto a
decisões aqui tá de grande poder a
objetivar o álbum nós é o é gol
excelente a 8 para o dia 14 de outubro
de 2007
é um orgulho que na áustria é 91% e nem
nada é igual a você ver o tempo estava
achando que a inflação deveria
ambos sabem nesse caso é o número de
doadores de órgãos
quando eu fiquei sabendo desse número me
perguntei por que afinal tem 99% de
doadores de órgãos porque na áustria
você já é doador de órgãos
você precisa pedir pra sair na dinamarca
você não é você precisa pedir para
entrar é uma palavrinha mágica que chama
de fogo
essa palavra é o que você já é sem fazer
nada são as decisões que eu chamo
decisões capitão nascimento você precisa
pedir pra sair alguma pessoa já tomou
essa decisão que você você tem que ir lá
e pedi pra sair
eu estava colocando crédito no celular
esses dias e aí uma duas opções uma
província temos em cima e outra para
receber o pé a 2005 estava desmarcado a
das ofertas estava matando alguém
decidiu que eu queria oferta que não
queria receber então fui lá e pedi pra
sair pra sair desmarcada o campo de maca
do recibo
o ubs tem uma funcionalidade nova tinha
culpa você pode compartilhar um carro
com outras pessoas
eu abri uberaba já marcado para pegar o
comum essa não podiam sair eu fui mesmo
público e até achei legal conhecer a
pessoa mas não conversa com o motorista
de uma van não sei se você se pega o
barueri só de pensar e aí o motorista de
uma vez em conta uma história e uma
senhora escolheu o culpo quando chegou
perto em outra pessoa no carro e ela
olhou estranho quando há sintomas em
outro passageiro está claro como ela
escolheu o corpo dela
a sony escolheu agosto sem saber ela
escolheu que já estava escolhido pela ré
é muito complicado isso é muito
interessante a gente imaginar quem toma
essas decisões
a gente foi no google hoje pesquisa onde
começou a pessoa tem 567 mil resultados
qual é a gente explica 91% você das
pessoas explica no resultado da primeira
página do google
será que quem escolheu um lugar que a
gente vai convencer o pessoal foi o
mesmo foi o globo
depois disso o que eu faço eu vou lá e
clicar na página 7
eu adoro a receita eu vejo lá porque tem
a paixão humana 47 aqui para pedir pra
sair
na verdade isso o google é o rubber
tando empurrãozinho para a gente eles
impõem vinhos inglês tem um nome na
economia comportamental também ter nome
eles são chamados de noites não é
exatamente um empurrãozinho inglês
eu queria te pedir pra vocês tornaram
conduzida por seu cachorro assim não
precisa quase 11 horas e à noite
existe uma teoria de um autor chamado de
traidor é um livro de maturidade e o
conselho editou dante é um nome que eu
dei uma forma simples da gente entender
desses lotes e cinco aninhos no mundo
digital
o engraçado foi que uma vez uma pessoa
foi na minha palestra no final da
palestra chegou pra mim e falou assim
agora eu entendi
eu pensava que a onu diz
agora nesta quaresma tirar uma foto
minha cortando g1
estou pensando que só quem carniça
europeu é da áustria e da dinamarca
todo mundo aqui recebeu um e mail de
confirmação de 10 nesse meio de um texto
escrito ao se inscrever também de uma
pessoa você está automaticamente sendo
poder de todas as suas decisões que você
vai tomar na sua vida
a uff que era eu
caso você não quer é fácil basta clicar
neste link e pedir pra sair
quantas pessoas clicaram no link mais
400 pessoas inscritas 13 pessoas ficaram
devendo então isso significa que eu
posso tomar todas as decisões da vida de
370 pessoas
não foi só uma experiência em si é uma
das coisas que eu faço eu faço esses
experimentos para entender como é que as
pessoas se comportam e eu mostro os
resultados
geralmente as pessoas me perguntam fato
tem esse conhecimento desses incômodos
vizinhos desses antes
isso pode fazer com que a gente manicure
alguém ea minha resposta que sim
o perigo disso é que sim o conhecimento
é uma ferramenta
se você tiver ele você pode usar para
fazer com que o encontro é uma coisa que
ela não precisa você pode usar para o
bem como por exemplo você pode usar para
fazer com que um paciente de a pele se
saiba o momento certo tomar insulina ou
você pode usar para evitar acidente de
caminhão como esse boneco é um esmalte
quer que faz a medição das ondas
cerebrais a detectar um cochilo para
evitar um acidente
então dessas 35 mil decisões
o que eu sei que tem muita decisão a ser
tomada e eu sei que cada vez mais a
gente toma essas decisões
mundo digital em um evento que aconteceu
em 2016 que fez com que as pessoas do
mundo 10 em 144 bilhões de passos que
você imagina que foi seu lançamento do
pokémon go pokémon gol do jogo que traz
à tona o conceito de realidade aumentada
cada vez mais a gente está imerso nesse
mundo de realidade aumentada realidade
virtual aprendizado de máquina e o que
eu sei é que o mundo digital está cada
vez mais presente na nossa vida
eu acredito que se a gente entender
melhor como esses empurrãozinho funciona
como esses não diz funciona a gente vai
poder construir um mundo melhor
a gente vai poder construir interfaces
melhores ea gente vai poder ser mais
consciente pra que a gente tome decisões
melhores
obrigado
[Aplausos]